sometimes watching a movie just isn't
enough you also want to eat that movie
that's why there's movie recipes today
we're going to show you how to make an
Ironman 3 birthday cake that is a
birthday cake that tastes exactly like
Iron Man 3 start with a store-bought
cake mix why should you invent the wheel
when you can just borrow from those who
have come before the original recipe
calls for mandarin orange but in order
to make the Ironman 3 birthday cake you
need to substitute an actual orange that
merely acts like a mandarin orange a few
drops of extremists which can be found
at any farmers market the guy in Man 3
birthday cake recipe calls for pepper
too much pepper stir it all together you
probably didn't end up pepper so go
ahead and add some more at an Iron Man
action figure to the center of the pan
to entice people to eat the dish now no
birthday cake is complete without a
message written in icing you can use
happy birthday if you want but I would
recommend finding a way to summarize and
a short few words what the movie says to
you before serving remember to remove
the action figure because there is no
Iron Man in Iron Man 3 take a shot of
whiskey Kollek it Appetit and enjoy mmm
barely better than the last one
[Music]